en ukraine qui a provoqué vous le savez
une explosion des prix des céréales la
russie est le troisième producteur
mondial de blé l'ukraine le huitième
autant dire donc des géants y at il des
risques de famine dans le monde comme le
prétend l'onu on pose la question à
notre invité nicolas bricas bonjour et
merci de nous rejoindre vous êtes socio
économiste au cirad le centre de
coopération internationale en recherche
agronomique pour le développement pour
le développement vous êtes titulaire
également de la chaire unesco
alimentation du monde d'abord est-ce que
l'on connaît l'impact de la guerre sur
la production les exportations de
céréales est ce que les affaires
continuent un peu à tourner ou pas du
tout
pour le moment ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il
ya 5 millions de tonnes de blé qui sont
bloqués dans les ports ukrainiens
il ya une une anticipation d'une hausse
des prix puisqu'on sait pas comment il
va évoluer le conflit qui fait monter
les prix sur les marchés internationaux
donc effectivement c'est ça qui fait
craindre qu'ils aient une crise
alimentaire parlait d'une grande famille
mondiale comme on l'entend parfois c'est
sans doute un peu exagéré
en fait ce qu'il faut regarder c'est
quels sont les pays pour lesquels le blé
est une base alimentaires représentent
plus du tiers de l'apport énergétique
pour les habitants et qui importent
massivement du blé donc il ya
effectivement des pays comme l'égypte
comme le maroc comme la tunisie comme le
yémen qui sont à la fois des gros
importateurs de blé et pour lesquels le
blé est une base alimentaire dans ces
pays là ce qu'on peut craindre c'est
qu'effectivement la hausse des prix
affecte particulièrement les ménages à
faible pouvoir d'achat et donc qui
pourrait entraîner des des émeutes on se
souvient des émeutes de la faim en 2017
en 2007-2008 ça pourrait se répéter
les émeutes en 2007-2008 et puis ensuite
en 2000 en 2011 le printemps arabe où
effectivement été déclenchée par des
hausses des prix met dans des situations
politiques dans lequel il y avait une
exacerbation de la population par
rapport au régime en place et donc que
c'est pas simplement quand les prix
montent que du coup ça a déclenché des
émeutes urna des pays qui ont connu des
hausses des prix ça c'est pas forcément
traduit par des émeutes mais il est vrai
que c'est un risque alors c'est un
risque pour un certain nombre de pays
comme je les dis qu'ils sont très
importateurs de blé pour lequel le blé
est important dans la consommation après
on à dos re pays qui importent beaucoup
du blé mais qui exportent en même temps
des produits pétroliers du pétrole ou du
gaz et ces pays aujourd'hui voient leurs
recettes d'exportation augmenter compte
tenu de l'augmentation des prix du
pétrole et du gaz sur le marché
international et donc ils peuvent
subventionner et donc ils peuvent
subventionner les prix des céréales en
tout cas aider les classes moyennes en
tout cas ils vont payer plus cher leur
blé mais ils vont gagner plus d'argent
en vendant du gaz et du pétrole donc en
termes de balance commerciale s'est pas
la catastrophe pour eux ils ont les
moyens de payer le renchérissement du
prix du blé après on a d'autres pays
dans lequel le blé est un on va dire un
aliment de complément qui est plutôt
utilisé le matin au petit déjeuner les
sandwichs etc c'est majoritairement le
cas de l'afrique au sud du sahara et ces
pays là effectivement vont être affectés
par une hausse des prix du blé mais le
blé n'est pas leur base alimentaire leur
base alimentaire c'est le maïs qu'ils
produisent eux mêmes c'est le manioc
qu'ils produisent eux-mêmes c'est
l'igname seigner baisser le mills et le
sorgho et c'est donc il faut pas non
plus dramatiser la situation
mais elle est effectivement inquiétante
est ce qui est un moyen de favoriser les
productions locales en afrique vous
parliez du millier du sorgho du manioc
utiliser ces matières premières qui sont
présentes et facilement exploitable sur
place dans ces pays là pour faire de la
farine
alors ça dépend des zones dans certaines
zones on peut produire du blé c'est plus
le cas du dd pays du nord du de
l'afrique des pays du bassin
méditerranéen au sud du sahara bien
évidemment tous ces pays là où engagée
en particulier depuis 2007 2008
d'ambitieuses politique d'augmentation
de la production de leurs propres
céréales racines tubercules banane
plantain et c'est en même temps on a
vraiment besoin d'un effort pour que ces
pays puissent au niveau de la recherche
trouver des solutions pour améliorer la
performance de leurs systèmes agricoles
il faut face à un accroissement
démographique rapide
et puis sans doute le fait que les prix
des produits importés en tout cas du blé
pour le moment augmentant et ben sahar
eux aussi leur production locale plus
compétitive puisque le différentiel de
prix entre les produits importés les
produits locaux est plus favorable du
coup aux produits locaux et elle aurait
eu une des grandes inconnues qu'on a
pour le moment c'est que beaucoup de
pays sont surtout dépendant du riz
importé et fatalement du blé en
particulier en afrique au sud du sahara
et pour le moment on n'a pas de monter
d'accélération de l'accroissement du
prix du riz le prix du riz il augmente
doucement depuis un peu plus d'un an
lors il vient d'une accélération donc on
est pour le moment rassurés mais on sait
pas comment ça va évoluer et il vient
d'où le riz le riz vient d'asie beaucoup
il vient d'inde il vient de thaïlande
il vient du pakistan ces sont les gros
exportateurs asiatiques du riz vers
l'afrique un petit peu des états unis
mais mais c'est majoritairement du riz
asiatique nicolas bricas je reviens
juste sur le prix des céréales le prix
du blé est ce que cette explosion est
justifié par ce qui se passe par la
guerre par l'arrêt de la production
l'arrêt des exportations est ce que
c'est aussi spéculatifs
alors d'abord le prix du blé et du riz
il a commencé à augmenter avant la
guerre avant la guerre en ukraine on
était déjà sur une tendance haussière
elle s'accélère avec la guerre avec la
rétention des exportations depuis depuis
l'ukraine
parce que les marchés fonctionnent comme
comme on appelle ça des marchés à terme
c'est à dire qu'on fonctionne sur la
base de contrats où on anticipe le prix
dans quelques mois et donc il ya
beaucoup de spéculateurs sur ces marchés
c'est comme ça fonctionne ces marchés
qui anticipent un risque de tensions sur
le sur le marché donc il ya plusieurs
solutions pour faire face à ça
aujourd'hui on avance beaucoup qu'il
faut relancer la production en fait il
faut pas oublier que la planète est
quand même au / production alimentaire
un simple une simple déclaration de la
réduction du taux d'incorporation du blé
et du maïs dans les agrocarburants
aujourd'hui vous savez que en france
dans l'essence est à 8 % d'éthanol
d'alcool qui viennent de la fermentation
du blé du maïs et de la betterave si on
réduit un peu la part de cet éthanol
dans les agrocarburants on fait tout de
suite baissé les prix sur le marché
international parce qu'on libère
d'importantes quantités de blé et de
maïs sur le marché destiné à ce
moment-là à l'alimentation humaine donc
il ya des moyens très simples à très
court terme de faire baisser les prix à
moyen terme on peut réfléchir au fait
que plus de la moitié des céréales sont
utilisés aujourd'hui en alimentation
animale et que on peut aussi chercher à
réduire l'usagé des céréales dans
l'alimentation animale pour re dégager
des volumes disponibles à l'alimentation
humaine ce qui contribuera également à
faire baisser les prix merci beaucoup
nicolas bricas pour votre équipe